ああ、
みなさん、こんにちは。久しぶりにパトレオン以外のライブストリームをやるのも楽しいかもしれないと思っ
たので、
ここにはすでにたくさんの人が
い
ます。
ライブストリームを行うのは楽しい私は長い間
非パトレオンのライブストリームを行っていない
ので
、人々がしばらくたむろしているかもしれない質問に答えるためにここにいるようなものです。
ある種の個人的なプロジェクトに取り組んでいる
いくつかのYouTubeに関連しているので、これは
私にとっては一種の中間ビデオで
もあるので、
とにかく楽しい
時間
を過ごせることを願っています
質問
ナルトから
ビーラップを殺すことができますええと、今あなたはそれをすることはできません私は
あなたが話していることを知っていますが
好きな非城陽漢字から漢字を学ぶ場所
漢字
だから漢字がジュリアじゃないのか正確に
はわからない
あの忍者よかんじそれはいいことだと思います
が、あなたは何年もの間どこにいましたか？
それで私はオイタ県
にいました。 ですから、九州の
ような
南西の島にあり、4つの大きな島の中で最も南西の島
です。ええと、私はまだここにいるので、おそらく
日本に市民権を持っているかどうかを示す良い兆候です。
今は5年間のビザを取得
しています。申請すれば永住権を取得できる可能性
がありますが、申請プロセス
は
、
youtubeyoutubeのような専業主夫には長すぎます。
私は双子の娘がいるので、今はそれをするのに十分な時間がありません
が、彼らが学校に行き始めたら、
おそらくそれを申請するつもり
であり、それを取得できるはずです、そしてええと、
私は知りません たぶん私の最初の試みは
大丈夫です
すごいこんにちは素敵な
ライブストリーがあります m
お子さんは元気ですええと私の子供は元気ですええと
彼らは今3歳くらいです
日本語の地域の違いを理解することを学ぶ私は
それを非常に
混乱させると思いますそれを理解する唯一の本当に方法
はそれに
没頭する
か、その方言を紹介するリソースがわからないように積極的に検索する
ことですが、
私は通常学習者に勧めません もちろん
方言を理解できれば大丈夫ですが
、教室で日本語を学べば
、
それは通常の
日本語99.99
の時間になりますが、教室の外では
ほとんどの入力が
地域の日本語のよう
になります。日本語を話す
と、ヒョジュンになることもあれ
ば、普通の日本語になることもあります。方言のようにホーガンになることもあります。
日本語を母国
語とする人
が、漢字のように、漢字
のアクセントのように
、少しずれて聞こえるので
、それと似ている
ので、私は もう一度、標準的な日本語に固執するように人々に勧めてください
ええ、世界で私のお気に入りの曲は
、伝説の
人です。
必要ですが
、私にとってはほとんどがフラッシュカードでした。
その後
、日本語でクリエイティブな書き方をしたり、漢字を勉強するのに役立った
日本の文学のようなものをかなり読んだり
しました。漢字を
勉強したことはありません。
漢字を集中的に
勉強しました。
漢字と語彙には
かなりの
重複がありますが
、この漢字を勉強するのではなく、
さまざまな読み方が好きなので、
代わりに漢字を勉強します。 時間が経つにつれて、
私は個々の漢字を勉強していなくても、私は
それらを拾うことができ
ましたええと
、日本のテレビ番組の推奨事項はありますか？
ええ、日本のテレビ番組
はテレビ番組ではありません
それは私がYouTubeチャンネルです
最近見て
いるので、今すぐチャットで入力します。
寄付をいただきました。ありがとうございました。ankitgoshに感謝します。
申し訳ありませんが、
番組はnakataまたはチャンネルと呼ばれている
ので、彼はコメディアン
です。 その
人は
60の何かを寄付しましたが、とにかくうまくいかない
かもしれません
が、寄付してくれ
て
ありがとうございます。チャンネル
は基本
的に面白い本のような本のように選ぶコメディーであり、彼は
通常はそれぞれ約20分の2つのビデオを使う
ので、40分のビデオの
ように、本の要約のように2つに分割して
、シェイクスピアでマクベスのようにやった後
、フィンの本のようにあらゆる種類のことをします。
彼が本を書いて
いるのは、
日本の
映画や他の日本の文学
のように人気のあるyoutuber umであるということです。彼が源氏物語をやったように
、それは
本当に面白かった
です。
今日は実際にコーヒーを飲んでいますが、
通常は飲んで
います
。youtubeまたはirlのいずれかで、日本で起こっている最新のトレンドは何だと思いますか。
年齢層が違うのは
明らかですが、
うーん、ツイッターで
もう少し時間を費やす
必要があります。ティックトックを見ると、
おそらく今は大きなもの
です。v
ツベルなので、バーチャルyoutuberは大きな
ものですが、それは親切です。 海外で
もそうです
が、日本で始まったとのことで、
ローガン、着替えたことがありますか
？ このiiの前
は、特にストリーム用に変更されたので、
一貫性を保つために、dai uh全体のようなカウンター
を理解するための秘訣を見てみましょう。
カウンターを理解する
ための秘訣
は、
それらを記憶せず、常にinを使用すること
です。 ユニバーサルカウンターな
ので、日本語と言うのではなく、
実際
には建物の床には不自然かもしれませんが、それが
秘密であるということを常に使用する
場合は、1セットとおそらく2、3のドーゲンを覚えるだけで済みます。
はげかかった外国人
は日本語と英語のどちらで考えていますか
それは両方の混合物のような
ものですそれは私がそれらの考えを持っている直前に私が使用していた言語に本当に依存します
なかたの動画は、
その後の私の思考プロセスは
、1時間
くらいは日本語になるとは
思いませんが、このような仕事を始めたら、 私は
英語を話しているので、
英語の考え方は
常にこれについて疑問に思っているよう
です。感情的なトーンが異なっていても、高低アクセントのルールが適用される
ので、これは
本当に良い質問で
あり、答えは通常
はいです。つまり、
イントネーションです。 ですから、話者
が
感情を単語やフレーズにマッピングする方法
は、通常、キーワードの一種
です。マジダと言った場合のように、この質問に答えようとしている間、私が本当に感謝しているすべての人の寄付に感謝します。
あなた
はそれが高低の単語であることを知っている
ので
、あなたが本当に驚いているように言って、あなた
があなたのスピーチにもっと感情を込める
ようになったとしても、それはまだ通常高から低になりますそれはちょうどそれが偶数のようになるでしょう
通常より高い
ので、私はあなたが知っているよりもマジダのようになります
ええ、それは
ほとんどの場合少し不自然になるでしょうとても
典型的なイントネーションは
確かに通常単語レベル
でそしてフレーズレベルでそれは本当に依存します
あらゆる種類のものですが、
通常
は
ペイチェックと高低アクセントのルールのフレームワーク内で機能するので
、スーパーチャットのコメントに戻ってみますねえドーガン
は私が1年間日本語を勉強してきた素晴らしいストリームを送信します
半分今
、あなたのすべてのビデオが素晴らしい仕事を続けているのを見てきまし
た。これ
はあなたが日本語の勉強でとても幸運だった2番目の寄付
だと思います。あなたが私のビデオを気に入ってくれて本当にうれしいです。
みんなががっかり
することはないので
、ひらがなからカタカナに変更
すると単語の
意味がどのように変わる
かわからない場合はツイートしました。 シンプルという意味
ですが、最後のumをカタカナまたはひらがなに変更すると、単純化すること
を意味します。
そうですね、ツイートが気に入ってくれてうれしいです。
まともなツイートだと思いましたが、
慎重にやってみます。 あなた
はええと
vチューバーを見ます ええと、私は
vチューバーを見ていません。私が今までに見
た唯一のyoutuberは、私が見たのです。
私のキーとコラボレーションしました。そうだと思いました。彼女の
名前は本当に面白かったと思います。彼らは本当に良い相性を持っていました。
そうそう、素晴らしいビデオでした。
素晴らしいビデオでした。オーケー
ドーガンオニギリがとても良かったと言って
ください。タッパーウェアを返却する必要があることを思い出し
ました。みんなのサポートに感謝します。
みんなが私のビデオをとても気に入ってくれてうれしいです。
これはパトレオンの外にある
ので、今のやり取りに本当に満足して
い
ます。他の誰かがスーパーチャットでコメントし
ました。ああ、雨が降っています。暴風雨
が
すべてのストリームとビデオと
レッスンに感謝します。 多くの
私はそれと重要な活力
も貢献してくれたことに感謝しますそしてあなたが州から
逃した最大のことをありがとうございました
ああそれは良い
質問です
うーん
私はおそらく
現代の技術が採用される速度を言うでしょう
州では本当に
簡単にできて
、お金を送金するのが好きなたくさんのアプリが
好きで、そのようなもの
は無料で、本当にとても使いやすい
ですが、日本
ではそういう種類のサービスがたくさんあります
あなたはまだそれらを使うことができませんあなたは
それらを通常支払うために使うことができますが
、人から人へのようにそれは
はるかに制限されているので、
ええとキアラは日本語を話します
実際
、ビデオの全体的な雰囲気を増すと思います。
たとえば、クローズドキャプションを使ってビデオを挿入
することができますが、FinalCutProやあなたのようにフォントを制御することはできませ
ん。 制御できませんでした 色
とサイズも同じくらい
私のビデオでは、細部の種類に非常にこだわっ
ている
ので
、事後にクローズドキャプションを知っていると
思いますが、これも焼き付けてほしいです。
それ
はビデオの一部ですそれ
は私の目にはビデオの個々のキャラクターのようなものな
ので、私はいつも同じフォントを常に
同じ色
を使用し、通常は同じサイズを使用します
やぶだん大丈夫です
から、外国人がいつまた日本に来ることができる
のか、それは本当に難しい
と思います。
おそらく6か月以内
に、ワクチン
ワクチン
ワクチンワクチンがいつ出てくるかによって異なります。
それが
出たら、もう少し行ってもいいと思います。
スーパーチャットのコメントをもう少し
お願い
します。日本語が流暢に話せるようになったのはいつですか。
日本に1年住んでからは日本語がとても流暢ですが、日本
に
来て1年になる前に何年も自分で日本語を勉強していたので、ベララスからこんにちは。
私はあなたの仕事に感謝するほど文化的ではありません
私たちはここにロシアの日本カイワクラブを持って
い
ますあなたはそれの多くのメンバーのためのインスピレーション
です素晴らしいです私は
ええと
私がどこでも日本人学習者のためのインスピレーションになることができることを本当に嬉しく思い
ます ええと、私の日本人は決して最高だとは思いません。私
と
同じように日本語を話す
本当に人気のあるユーチューバーがたくさんいるということ
ですが、
他の人にも日本語を勉強するように促すことが
できれ
ば、私は」 とても嬉しいです
。今後の勉強に頑張ってください。
寄付してくれてありがとうございます。
ごめんなさい。これらの
コメントは、予想よりも少し
早く届き
ます。ありがとうございます。 ええと、すごい
g この肌寒い秋の天気に最適だったのが大好きですええと、
今何を読んでい
ますかええと、今は日本の文学を読んでいませんええと、
今は新しい日本の文学を読んでいません。
それは良い本だったとは言い難いですが
、日本で1〜4杯のコーヒーを見てみましょう。私は
それを最も感謝していると思い
ます。将来は確かにそれをコーヒーに費やします。
寄付は大丈夫です。 あなたのチャンネルは
私が英語と日本語の両方を勉強するのにとても役立ち
ますいつもありがとう私の喜び
私の喜びありがとう大丈夫あなたはどれ
くらい日本語を勉強してきたのか見てみましょう
この時点で、
あなたとクリス・ブロードは私に
日本への日本の移動を学ぶように促しました私は
今学期にクラスを受講し始めましたそれは本当に
難しいですすべてに感謝します
素晴らしい
クリスは素晴らしい人です明らかに彼は
素晴らしいコンテンツも作っています
彼と私が
あなたや他の人たちに日本語を学ぶためだけに刺激を与えてくれることを嬉しく思います。
また日本に
来て試してみてください。日本に来るできるだけ多くの人が試してみてください。
自分の状況を
実際に試して、
実際
に日本で成功させることができる程度ii数年後には
、日本で本当に楽しい時間を
過ごしてしまう人もいれば、数年後
には轍に陥る人もいます。 彼らは
そんなに良い時間を過ごしていないので、彼らは
ちょっとがっかりしました
、そして
ええと、私はそれ
についての別のビデオを将来作りたいと思っ
ていますが、ええと、
私はそのクリスと 私は再び
あなたに刺激を与えることができました、そしてあなた
が
日本に滞在し、ここであなたの時間を楽しんで
くれること
を願ってい
ます。 それは
生きているすべての人にとって良いことです ここで、
ええと、ええと、ええと
、それはテレビと同じくらい日常生活で厳しい男ですええ、それは
本当にあなたが誰と話すかによって異なり
ます私は男が
おそらく
25歳から35
歳
のように最も厳しいと思います
その年齢層
の人々のその年齢範囲の多くの人々は、
ええとyoutubeの
ようなもののために、
そして
留学などのようなもの
が netflix
と
私は、
その年齢層の人々から、ガイダイゴを使用している
人々を
見て、
英語を使用できるように、または単に次のように使用できるように、おそらくインテリジェントに聞こえようとしているように見えると思います
標準的な日本語です
が、25から35のようなものの中で、
それは本当に悪い
ですえ
えと、そのトレンドのファンではありません。
トラックといつも面白いです
私はあなたの
寄付とあなたの将来の
勉強に感謝しますええと語学学校
ドーガン日本の家族と話すための最良の方法は何
ですか
]具体的には、
あなたが何を求めているのか完全にはわかり
ません。
素晴らしいビデオは彼らのためにたくさんのことを学び
ます。初めて日本に行く人からのヒントに感謝します。
心を開いて
試してみてください。 敬意
を表して、それは良いことです。パリの曲がりくねった最初の期間にポールテイラー
からの10時間のライブストリームを見て、
今はドーガンがライブで
いいセットアップです。ユーモアのセンスが大好きです。
翻訳
研究は日本では良い考えですえ
えと、私はそれをお勧めしません、そしてそれは
私が
この種の個人的な
仮説だと思うからですが、
大体において
翻訳はoになるだろうと思います
比較的近い将来
、
機械学習のおかげで、
おそらく重大な
大規模なイベントの
ようになると思います。今のように、コンピューター
を介して機械を介して行われる機械学習の翻訳
は、ネイティブチェックが必要なため、まだかなり悪いです。
おそらく5、6
年、あるいは10年以上もそのように続くと感じますが、その後も
おそらくこの画期的なものになるでしょう。
仕事を休んでいる
翻訳者がたくさんいるので、翻訳は
、中学や高校
、さらには大学のように日本語を勉強している人に、
あなたがそう思わないのであれば、追求することをお勧めします。
それは、10年ほどでキャリアの選択として非常に有利なものになるでしょう。それ
は私自身の個人的な
信念のようなものです。
申し訳ありませんが、その前にもう一方に行かなくてはなりません。
英語でバイリンガルの子供たちとあなたの妻とのあなたの経験は何でしたか。
私が彼女と中国語で話そうとするとイライラします。
私たちは
ビジネスレベルの日本語も話しますが、彼女は私を呼んでいます。
妻
と
一緒に始めたのですが、最初はほとんど日本語
でしたが、どういうわけかわからないのですが、
それはおそらく
仕事である程度英語
を使い始めたからだと思います。 家でもっとだまされて
、今ではほとんどが家で英語になっている
ので、実際にはまったく問題ではありません。
家で主に英語を使うのは自然なことな
ので、子供たちと一緒に、ほとんど英語を使ってみます。
なぜなら、私の日本語
は非常に高いレベルだ
と思いますが、それでもネイティブレベルではないので、私の子供たちがネイティブの入力を取得したほうがいい
でしょう。
外の家は日本語になり、家の中は
おそらくもっと
英語になります。
日本を一周するのに一番好きなエリアは何ですか。
日本で一番好きなエリアは、
おそらくベップ以外にもっと好きかもしれません。
beppuは
横浜の湊みらいよりも
ランドマークタワーのフェリスホイールでそのエリアが大好きです
それは私の
お気に入りの場所であり、日本で一番好きな場所
です
ちょっとオースティン
ちょっとおいおい、ここにいてくれてうれしいよ。
私たちが追いつく必要があるサポートに感謝します。
私たちがチャットしたことを知って
います。 この後、
別のメッセージを送信しなかったことをお詫びし
ますが、今
はかなりの数の人が見ているので、ポップインして
いただきありがとうございます。後でまた連絡します。
ニバーシティがチャットに
飛び込んできましたええと、fバーとええと
、私は頭のてっぺんから
これら2つのことを覚えていませんが、
私は日本の市民権を真剣に考えています。
今は二重課税されるのが好きではありません
私は私の税金の大部分を支払います私の税金の大部分は
地元の日本人に支払います日本の
連邦政府と
地方政府もそうです
がそれから私もアメリカの税金を申告しなければなりません
日本でアメリカ人がそれをするのは非常に複雑なので、それは完了するのに少なくとも30時間かかります。
特に、フリーランスのアメリカ人
がyoutubeやpatreonの
ようなことをするように、そして私は少なくとも30時間かかるのです。
これは本当にあなたが収入を計算する方法に依存します
が、それは
私がアメリカの会計に支払わなければならないものに加えて私にとっておそらく1000ドル以上です
ntと私も
州のirsに支払わなければならないものに加えて、私
が日本の市民権しか持っていなかった場合、
私は両方の潜在的な収入でどれだけ節約できるかという点でおそらく年間5000ドル以上自分自身を節約することができます
追加の時間から、そしてまた米国政府にお金
を与える必要がないことからの節約
も
そうですそうそうそうそうそうそう私はそれを考えてい
ます
日本で何かが起こった場合
や、経済が完全に
崩壊した場合などの
ように話すと、明らかにそれはいつでも
荷造りして州に戻ることができるので
、決断するのは難しいですが
、あなたのチャンネルとあなたのビデオに出くわします
ほぼ7年後、日本語の再学習を手伝ってくれました。
それを聞いてとてもうれしく思います
。今後の勉強も
頑張ってください。彼がどこにいるのか見てみましょう。
これ
はまともなジョークだと
思いました他の人も気に入ってくれてうれしいです
はい
私はそのビデオを作るのも楽しかったです
寄付を
してくれたみんなに
感謝します この時点まで、
誰かが言った
ええと、私はこの部屋でバックフリップを行うことはできません、
そして私は長い間バックフリップをしていません
が、私が
今することは私が何をするかをあなたに教えることです
私がドーガンをだましているビデオをリンクして、
それをチャットに入れます。誰か
がそのえ
えと、私がバックフリップやそのようなことをしているのを見たいのなら
、私はそのようなことをすることができまし
た。
ビデオ
トリッククワッド
クワッドそれはクワッドクワッドだった
私はこれがビデオ
おっと
大丈夫だと思うのでここで
それは大丈夫だと思います
大学時代にフリップなどをやってい
た私の古いビデオは大丈夫です。
去年の10月に日本を訪れました。メトロで
ええとイビスの発表が出るたびに笑いを抑えなければなりませ
んでした。この種の
記憶がすべての
個々の
ミームを覚えてくれてうれしいです。
私がよく持っている一番の秘訣
は、日本の映画を選ぶことです。私がお勧めする日本の映画は、十二種
のやさしにほんじんと呼ば
れてい
ます。
映画の文字通りすべての行のように記憶され、
基本的なuh anki
uh grammar、uh、そしてvocabのようなものと組み合わせてそれ
を行うと
、たくさん覚えることができるので、
こんにちはdogan私はあなたのスーパーマーケットのスキットが大好き
です
それはおそらく私のお気に入りのスキットの1つ
なので、
そのような人々や
ドーゲンのような人々
が
、jeを介して日本に行くことを両親に納得させようとしている人々に何かアドバイスがありますか？ このプログラムは、
一生に一度の良い機会
です。出身地によって異なりますが
、日本
では、犯罪率などの一般的な点で非常に安全
ですが、 それを超え
て、
みんな、どういうこと
を言うの
？ジョルスキーをもう一度どう言うの？
コロナウイルスのせいで安全のためにここでは誰もがマスクを着用している
ので
、日本では現在の米国のほとんどの地域と比べて、日本ではおそらく安全
です。ヘルスケアは本当に良いです。本当に
安いです。 ええと、特に今は日本
に来るのに本当に良い時期です、
そして
ええと、コロナを超えて、私
は日本も
将来、
特にoのようにやっている人々にとって本当に良い場所だと思います
nline work
そしてそれはまた日本が
とても
安全で素晴らしい素晴らしい住む場所であり、
四季
が素晴らしいので東京の外での生活費
はかなり高いですが
東京の外ではほとんどの
場所でかなりリーズナブルです 東京と同じくらい便利で
安全ですが、
オンラインで
何かをしていて、州などから収入を得ている場合は、日本に住む
ことのメリットを実際
に享受でき、健康を増進することができます。
保険と安全
で素晴らしい食べ物やそのようなものへのアクセスを持っ
て
いますが
、オンラインから安定した収入源を得ることができれ
ば
、オンライン作業を行うことのメリットも享受できます。
ほとんどの場合、日本は
技術の面で米国に少し遅れている
ので、
近代的な技術を導入するなどの面で多くのビジネスがあります。
地元の日本の企業が
あなたの両親を納得させるのに役立つことを願っています私は
ジェットプログラム
をやりましたそして私は今のところに非常に満足し
ています
日本の他のキャリアに外国人として
うん、それはまさに私がやったことです私は
3年間ジェットプログラムをしました
私は1年後にええと英語を教えました
私は
約6ヶ月間韓国に行きましたそして私は
少し日本に行き来しました
当時はクリエイティブなライティングに専念していましたが、
その後日本に戻って塾のよう
な地元で
1年ほど英語を教えて
から働き始め
、日本のアプー大学に通いました。
そこで学生募集をしていて、今はフルタイムでyoutubeをやっている
ので
、ジェットプログラムは私にたくさんのつながりを与えてくれたので
、ドアに足を踏み入れること
ができました。  pの場合 初めて
日本で働き、英語をやっ
ている人は仕事をし
ているの
ですが、すでに
他のキャリアへの進出を計画しているので、おそらく良い場所にいる
ようですが、将来の道は
そうしないと、先ほど簡単に話していた
ような外国人が英語を教えていることに陥ることがあります。
多くの人は、日本文化が好きな
ので、日本に住むためだけに英語を教えるのが好きだと確信してい
ます。 でも彼らは
英語を教えるのが
好きではなく、日本で2、3年くらい過ごした後、ある日目を覚まし、1日
8時間のよう
に仕事をしている
ので、お金を稼ぐのが嫌いです。
そうなると
、日本での生活の良い面を無視し始め
ますが、日本で好きなことを
やり直すことができれば、私のようなオンライン作業のような
ものでも、多分
ソニーのような日本の大手企業のように
仕事をして
いるのか、スクウェア・エニックスのように翻訳の
仕事をしている友達が
いるのかわからない。
日本でのあなたの仕事はまた
住むのに素晴らしい場所
ですあなたが実際に英語を教えるのが好きでない限り、
英語の
轍にとらわれないでください
私の好きな
日本ベースのチャンネルを介して
笑良い仕事を続け
てくださいええと
、彼らはあなたの交換を強制的にキャンセルすることができないと聞いて非常
に残念
です 私の人生の最高の経験は、
来年かコロナの治療ワクチンが出たら来られることを願っています
が、
それまでの間、私はあなたを少なくとも少し楽しませることができ
てうれしいですこんにちは私は工業で勉強している英国人です
コロンビアのデザイン私は
日本に転勤するのではなく、どうやってそれをどうやってやるの
かについてアドバイスはありますか？
それは
難しいですそれは非常に
難しい
です
あなたの特定の状況についてもう一度よく知っています
が
、あなたの日本人が十分に日本でそのビジネスを行う
ことができるようにウェブサイトを設定し、英語を教える
ことでドアに足を踏み入れることができるなら、おそらく日本に
来てください
最初に英語を教え
て、それをやって
いるとき
に、しっかりした接続を作ってからおそらく1、2年後に工業デザインを行う
ことができるようにいくつかの接続を試してみてください。
-
ビザを取得するのは非常に難しいでしょう
。私
は真剣に日本を勉強し始めたすべての努力のおかげで、
私は
誰もがそれを宝石に
する宝石ではあり
ません。正直なところ、それについて満足しています。  ly私は前進するために何をすべきかわからない
ええと
私の友人ええとマット対日本私は
彼が流暢に
なりたい日本語を勉強している人々のために一種の長期的になるであろう人々のための本当に良いロードマップを持っていると思います
長期的には、長期的には
マット対日本のチャンネルをチェックして
みてください。彼のアプローチは本当に良いと
思います。チャットをスキップします。いいえ、わかり
まし
た。大丈夫です。 外国人
として日本人の友達を作るのは難しいと
聞いたのです
が、そこに住んで
いるとどう思いますか？
私はまだ
少し話をしているapuの同僚で
、彼らは私の友達だと思いますが、私は
決して外出せず、週末に飲み物を飲むのが好きで
、
外出して他の人と運動するのが好きです。
一人でいるのが好きで
、仕事をするのが
好きです。 キングユーチューブの動画で
そのようなことを読んでいます
が
、私自身の経験から、
日本に住む西洋人と同性の友達を作るのは難しいという
考えに同意します。それ
は主に価値観のわずかな違いによるものだと思います。
外国人が日本人の
ようにぶらぶらしているようなデフォルトのやり方と、一
人一人が
自分の趣味に情熱を注いでいる度合い
は非常に違うと思うので、そのためだと思います
確か
に、自分の家の文化でのようなものと比べて、普通の
友達のようなものを作るのは難しいかもしれません。
日本人の男
dyotaroと
natsuki私はそれが彼の名前だと思いますが、ええと
、それは素晴らしいですそれは
あなたが知っていることは素晴らしいですそれの
ために私はクリスに本当に満足し
ています
もう少し孤独なので
、
外に出て追求するような関係で
はありません。
最初にここに来たとき
は、ジェットプログラムで本当に幸せでした。
仕事が終わって部屋にいるようなもので、ライティングやクリエイティブなものを書くのが好き
なのですが、そういう
ことは難しいかもしれません。
すでに典型的な日本人とは少し違う価値観を持っているかもしれませんが
、
本当の典型的な日本人は
いないので
、
[音楽]と
は言い難い
です。 聞いたことがないので、聴くのに
最適なバンド
はgogo7188です。本当に洗練された音楽に興味があるなら
、おそらく史上最高の
日本のロックバンドだと思い
ます。
cそれから彼女の
ナリンゴと東京事変も本当に良い
ですが、彼らはしばしばとても
洗練されて
いるので、あなたのように
彼らの音楽を本当に感謝するために特定の気分に入る必要がありますそれはとても複雑な
ので、gogo7188は少しだと思います
もう少し
内臓的で生で、すぐに
入るのが好きな
ので、gogo7188とスーパーカー
の2つのバンドは両方ともすでに
解散していますが
、おそらく私の意見では
、
これまでに出された最高の日本のアルバムのいくつかを持っているので、
ええと、あなたは何ですか？ この7月に行く
予定の日本語学校
についてもジェットプログラム
には4年の
学位
が必要ですか
？圧倒的多数の人が思うように、4年の学位は必須またはほぼ必須であると私は理解しています
それ
はジェット機に乗っているので
、誰もが持っているか、
ほとんどの人が持っていると思うので、
日本語の学校が本当に良いのはおそらく良いことです
いくつかのこと
はありますが、他のことにはあまり良くありません。
最近のシリーズでこれについて話します。
私の視聴者は、日本人の文化的要素の種類
について学び、ネイティブの先生から直接フィードバックを得るのに本当に良いと批判しています。
スピーカーですが、同時に
教室の言語で
あなたが聞くことになる日本語の多くは
、すみませんネイティブスピーカー
からのものであり、それは少し有害である可能性が
あるので
、すべての学習方法の賛否両論
基本的
に日本に住んでいる西洋人スターターパックnihongojoules
は私の考えを変えました私はnattoが大好きです実際にはとても
健康的ですそしてそれ
はk2ですそれは
あなたにとって本当に良い栄養素です
私が見ている日本のyoutuberのほとんどが
完璧な日本のこの画像を作成しているという幻想になり始めています
私が日本に行くと私
は失望
するかもしれませんええとこれは半種類のcontrかもしれません
言い過ぎですが
、外国人の種類によって扱いが異なるのは確か
ですが、見ているだけでも、私のような白人だけが知っているような、一連の人々の間でもそうです。
日本では
、彼らは本当に幸せだ
と感じ、彼らは本当にそれが好きで、
彼らは
彼らが満足しているキャリアを築くことができたのです。
再びその英語の
[音楽]
轍に陥り
、日本に幻滅する人
もいるので、少なくともある程度
は、あなたの
見通しと
、これを実現するためにどれだけ決めるかによって異なります。
繰り返しになり
ます
が、日本は誰にとっても同じだと言っ
ているのではありません。
私は自分の経験からしか話せ
ないの
ですが、前向きな見通しを持つことでしか利益が得られないのであれば、私はそうだと思います。
そう言って
みよう
こんにちはドーガンありがとうございますそしてまた
私のような多くの人々
と私は多分クリス・クリス・ブロードも言うでしょう
が、私たちは日本でポイントを持っていますそれは
ああ
これはこれです
多分私は州に戻るべきかもしれないように本当に荒いですが、
あなたはあなたがその厳しい期間を経て余分な仕事をすることを知っています
そしてそれから
あなたはその反対側に出てき
て本当に本当に
本当に良い場所にいることを願っています 時間と労力を費やしてくれてうれしいです。それがすべての人に可能
かどうかはわかりません
が
、前向きな見通しが
あなたに役立つこと
を願っています。
私は日本語を勉強して1年目ですが、
あなたのビデオ
はあなたのコメディスタイルをどのように発展させたのかを教えてくれ
ました。これについては少し前に話しまし
たが、
すみません、最初はクリエイティブな文章を書こうとしました。
本当に
見上げると一流だと思います
三島
由紀夫のような作家と私はアーネスト・ヘミングウェイのようなものを知りません、そして
私は小説家である
という概念に
、それ自体を書くという実際のような
工芸品よりも少し好きでした、そして
ええと、起こったことは
私の種類全体で何度もあります 執筆の旅
と私が過ごしたのは
、大学卒業後5〜6年の大部分は、本当に
創造的な執筆に集中し
ていたと
思います。その期間中に、あなたの執筆はあまり良くないと言う人々からフィードバックを得ることが何度もありました。 あなた
はそれを本当に真剣にしよう
としますが、少しリラックスして
もう少しコメディーな
ことをするとき、それは本当に面白いかもしれません、そして私は
実際に私に
彼らが言ったのとまったく同じことを私に言った大学の教授がいました あなたが本当に
書く
ことを追求したいなら、あなたはコメディを追求するべきですこれは
あなたの強いスーツのようですあなたの強み
はコメディをするあなたはコメディが得意かもしれない
ので
それは私が現実ではなかったものでした
以前は真剣に考えた
ことはありますが、それ以来、それをやっていることを知ら
なかったので
、うまくいきました。申し訳ありませんが、本当に早く上がるつもりです。
誰かがええと尋ねました。
申し訳ありませんが、
私はいくつかのコメントを逃したと思いますえ
えと、私の妻は通常
、私たちの場所でご飯を作って
います。
私自身と私は
トラッシュテイストの
ポッドキャストに参加し
たいと思っています。彼らがそのことを確立して以来、私はジョーイと少し連絡を取り合っています。
自分を無理矢理押し付けて
、子供を育てるの
とか、日本に
住んでいるのか、九州に住んでいるのか、ちょっと忙しいですが、もう少し時間があれば、
おそらく比較的近い将来に
なります。
そして私は東京を訪れることができ
ます私はおそらく私たち全員が集まり、
多分私はtにいるだろうと想像することができます ラッシュ
テイストポッドキャストそれはとても楽しいだろう
私は
それらの人はすべて素晴らしいと思いますええと
、私が日本語を勉強した最初の年のコンテンツに感謝
しますねえドビンを見てみましょう コメディコメディスタイルを開発しましたか？
私にとっては
、
コメディをやってみるのと同じような
ものでした。コメディの鍵の1つだと思います。
または、一般的なクリエイティブな文章の種類がわかりません。
クリエイティブな努力は、好きな
ものと嫌いなものを常に探して、
なぜ、なぜ嫌いなのかを自問したいということです。
ポリシー
と私のツイッターを見たことがあるなら、
おそらくこれを知っているでしょうが、私
は絵文字を絶対に使用
しません。なぜなら、私は絵文字が好きではないからです。
ええと、
2年かそこら2年かそこらで絵文字を決して使わないように
私は私を置くことを余儀なくされました n
多くの絵文字が何を表現しているのかを明確にするために必要な追加の努力は、
今、たくさんの絵文字がチャットに登場して
いるのですが、
私がよく人々に言うように、これ
が本当にええと時代のソニーのように聞こえるかどうかはわかりませんが
私の意見では、あなたの創造的なライティングをすぐに改善するための最良の方法の1つは、人生の
あらゆる面で絵文字の使用をやめることです。そうすると、私の意見では、ライティングライティングゲームを強化
する必要が
あります。
ええと、寄付してくれて
ありがとうええと、大好きな本スラッシュライトノベル
私の好きなライトノベルは、おそらく
その本が私の心を吹き飛ばしたケインによる
ものです。 ええ
、おそらく私のお気に入りの軽い小説
日本の潜水艦
ねえ犬と先生はどうやって日本のアパート
の賃貸または購入の
問題を回避したのですか
私はいつも私が経験することはどれほどの悪夢であるかを聞きます
内容
はみんなの状況にもよるけど
、日本でアパートを借りるのに苦労した
ことは一度もない
ので、前もってたくさんの料金がかかるので多額のお金を払わなければなら
ないのですが、私が拒否されたことは一度もありません。
私はベップとオイタンに住んでいるので、外国人だったのかもしれませんが、
ここには外国人がたくさんいます
が
、YouTubeで主に非アジア人の外国人
が日本の経験を共有しているのを見ると、問題はありませんでした
日本でアジア系アメリカ人のスラッシュアジア人であることについての洞察私は他の人に代わって話したくないので、それが私にとって
一種の危険地帯であるかどうかはわかりませんええ、私は
代わって話したくないです
iiは私自身のためにしか話すことができないので、他の人の
彼はあなたを持っているかもしれないチャンネル
私のような西洋人とは対照的に、日本に住んでいるアジア人としての非アジア人または非白人の人であることがどのようなものである
かについての
考え
日本人
は、あなたが
日本で生まれ育ったわけではないことを知るまで、もっと日本人
に振る舞うことを期待
しているように見えます。
彼らはすぐに
あなたがここで生まれ育ったのではないと思い込んでいますあなたは
平均的な人と比べて少し余裕があるかもしれません
が明らかに100人の日本人に見えるなら
それは少し違うでしょう
典型的なアメリカ人と典型的な
日本人のようなステレオタイプのステレオタイプのファッションは100異なるので、
100 umの民族的に日本人であっても
、アメリカ人のように服を着れば、
あなたはまだ目立ちます 日本では、
メイクやそのようなもののように
、日本の人々が使用
するスタイルは
、アメリカ人が使用するスタイルとはまったく異なり、
すぐに自分を表現するのが難しいことに気付くでしょう。
私はファンボーイであり、
私は
代名詞や他の女性の文の構造としてワタシを使用します
が、友達を作るのは難しいです
特にみんな私
も一瞥するでしょう私は
芸術家タカヤンがそれをどのように行うのかわかりません
若い男性が使用することはかなり少ないので、
私はあなたに
本当に多くのアドバイスを与えることができないだろう
と思います。なぜなら
、あなたにとって重要な場合、あなたが
その特定の代名詞を使用したいのであれば
、現在の理由だけで
ええと、この時点での日本社会のあり方
はあまり一般的ではないので、ある程度
の摩擦があると思い
ます。 あなたの友人グループは
あなたと同じような価値観を持っているあなたのような他の人々を見つけるかもしれませ
ん
、そしてそれはおそらく
問題には
ならないでしょう、しかしそれはおそらく常にではない
でしょうが近い将来ある程度はおそらくそうなるでしょう
シェルターの男性が最初
に多くの人と交流する際にある程度目立つものな
ので、
私はすでに
感謝して
います。 会ったあなたの日本語の
声と痛いそしてあなたの英語の声
と痛い
ええとそうなら結果はどうですかはいと
いいえええと
私は私の声のスペクトログラフのように見えるようにプラットのようなプログラムのようなサービスを使っています
私が
パトレオンで音声学を教えるとき、
それは本当に依存します。なぜなら
、私は日本語のキャラクターが好きなことがある
ので、サラリーマンの
キャラクターが好きな
の
です。
とにかく私のチャンネルではステレオタイプに反対するようなものです
が、サラリーマンのキャラクターですが、それから私は、シアクショーや
私などの誰かについて話している場合のように、迷惑なキャラクターと言うような他のキャラクターをやります
インタラクションが
特に迷惑なようにし
たいと思います。同じことを何度も何度も書くようにさせてくれ
ます。そうすれば、私は低い
声や高い声の
ようになり
ます。 それを始めて
、YouTubeである程度さまざまなキャラクターをやって以来
、私の種類のデフォルトの
日本の音声
周波数のように忘れてしまいましたが、かなりの量の
証拠が
あり、これも議論されていますが、いくつかの
証拠
はデフォルトを示唆しています 日本人はデフォルトでは
ありませんええ
、日本の声の基本周波数は
アメリカの請求書よりも日本よりもわずかに高いです。
通常、日本語
ではピッチが高くなり、
高いままである場合が多くなります。英語では
、
通常、上下、上下、上下に
なります。たとえば、ハイボンの
言葉の
ように、低く始まり、
低くなります。 それ
は日本語
の高低アクセントのようなもの
で、言語の構造の1つですが、
英語にはそれがないので、
上がると上がると
すべての単語
に個別のアクセントがあるため
、日本語では
ピッチが高くなり、高いままで
あることが一般的であるため、通常はすぐに元に戻ります。これが、基本周波数または私がいつかわからない理由の1つである可能性があります。
英語と日本語の平均頻度のように見えますが
、日本語の方が高いと言う人もいますが、日本人と西洋人の
ように、音声器官自体のように関係があると言う人もいます。
おそらく組み合わせです。
複数の
ことを考えていますが、この時点で私
は
ほとんどの場合
、英語と比較して日本語で少しだけ高くしよう
としましたが
、声を下げたり、テクスチャを追加したりすること
はもうありません。
私のyoutubeビデオです
が、日本語でさまざまなピッチのアクトやパターンを打つ能力が
実際に損なわれていることがわかったので、もうそれをしません
。あなたの質問に答えることができれば幸いです。
ところで、あなたのコンテンツが大好きです。
私のような人や他のみんなが
日本語を学ぶのに苦労
していますええと、これについては少し前に話しましたが、ええと日本は私自身の生活の中で素晴らしい場所
です。
完全に
、そしてあなたは実際に楽しんでいる仕事をすることができ
ます
そして日本に住んでそして日本の文化
からのすべての利益を享受する
それはあなたが[ __ ]で
非常に
やりがいのあるそしてええと幸せな生活を送ることができるということです
ほとんどの人がええと、それ
があなたのやる気を起こさせてくれると思います。日本語が少し話せれば勉強できれば
、日本の音楽のような日本の映画のようなアニメのようにもっと鑑賞できるものがたくさんあります。
日本語を理解
すれば
、
英語の字幕や
母国語で何
が起こっているのかを理解できた場合と比べて、よりインパクトのあるアニメのシーンがたくさんあります。
ほとんどの人にとって一番のことは
、あなたが最終目標を持っていない場合、あなたの最終目標は何であるかということだと思います。そう
すれば、あなたが本当にやる気を起こさせることは不可能だと思いますが、
私のようなあなたの目標が
恣意的な例これは私が
やっていることだからです私は日本のユーチューバーになる
つもりですそれはあなたがその
ような感じが好き
であなたが本当にそれ
ならそれはただ続くでしょう llyやる気を起こさせる
日本の音楽やアニメのような日本のメディアを楽しんでいるなら
、そのようなコンテンツを定期的に見たり聞いたり
することもやる気を起こさせることができる
と思います[音楽]大丈夫なので、この人の
日本人
は確かにいくつかあると思います ええと、そうですね、
ワタシを使っている日本人男性はたくさん
います。あなたのスピーチでできることは他にもある
と思います。
ワタシを使うことについて話
していた以前の人は、
彼らのスピーチに
は、
ワタシを使用するだけでなく
、
よりフェミニンでフェミニンなスピーチパターンを示す
ような他のこともあると言ったので、1つの例のように
、1つまたはあなたになる多くのことを言うようなものです」
[音楽
]のように、通常は女性らしい
ので、マクロレベルでは
、ワタシ以外にもたくさんの
ことがあると思いますが、それは本当です。
ワタシを使うとそれほど目立たなくなるかもしれ
ない
ので、指摘してくれてありがとう
[音楽]
誰かに聞いたり、ちょっとスケベなコメントを言ったりして
くれてありがとう。 寄付
um私の英語の平均は115ヘルツです私の
日本語は170ishです私は今130ishに変更しました
今私はより高いピッチで話すピッチでより正確になり
ますええほとんどの人にとってそれは必要ではないと思います
が私は自分自身を見つけました
ピッチを少し上げてみると
、日本語に存在するさまざまなウムピッチとアクセントパターンを正確に打つことができる人がいる
ので、それ
はあなたの状況にも役立つかもしれません。
ちなみに、私はおそらく20分
ほどで小川に出るつもりです。
多分ちょっと依存します。
最初に1秒水を飲む必要があります。申し訳あり
ませんが、今でもソフトボールを聴いていますか。
それから絶対に私は
ソフトボールが大好きで、
彼らの音楽は
私
が最初に日本に恋をした一番の理由のようだっ
たので、
私はおそらく彼らを聴き続けるためにいつも彼らに耳を傾けるでしょう
漢字の認識に苦労し
、発音を覚えるのに苦労した年
これはちょっと物議を醸す
意見かもしれませんが、多くの理由で漢字だけに集中
しようとすることはほとんどの人にとって生産的ではないと思い
ます
現代日本
では、ほとんどの場合、
学校に行く
ように、最後に何かを書いたときのことを文字通り思い出せないほど非常に低い場合を除いて、ほとんどの場合、日本や漢字を物理的に書き出すことになります。
日本語
今では、キーボードやスマートフォンを使うようにすべてデジタルになっ
ているので、覚える
必要はあり
ません。漢字の書き方がわからなくても、
それ以上のことはできます。 ええと
、外国語に取って代わられるようになっている言葉がたくさんあるので、
私は
これについて何年にもわたって多くの冗談を
言いましたが、あなたが
2、3年のようにええと漢字
を覚えてから日本に来るように 日本人
は西洋のローンワードに相当する言葉の
ように使う言葉すら使わないので、最近ツイッターに載せた例の1つは、
持続可能なという言葉のようなものです。
その単語の高低アクセントはわかり
ませんが、最近の日本で
は、ガイアの単語のように言うので
、たくさんの日本語を聞いて、話すことに
集中したほうがいいと思います。
マスターのようなソロのようになりたいのでなければ、カンジを覚えているのではなく、
それは
本当にあなたのお気に入りの
高低アクセントのレストランや高低アクセントのエリアに依存します
ええ私は高低アクセントに行ったことがありません
永遠
に私がワシントン大学に通っていたとき
、あなたはアベニューに降りてしばらく北に行き、
このハワイアンレストラン
を通り過ぎて道路の左側に行くと思う場所が1つありました
焼きそばのような麺を作ったこの中華料理店がありました
が、もっと中華風のようなものでした。マイケルがあなたのメッセージを撤回
したのは本当に良かった私のお気に入りの場所の1つだったと思い
ますが、
後でもう一度コメントしたようです。
すぐにやってみようと
思いますええと、安定することについてどう思いますか
、ええと、これは何ですか私はこれを
調べなければなりませんかパンクラックまたは
パンクロック
よくパンク私は日本で最近のパンクロックをあまり聴いていません
が私は
2000年代初頭のように、
ソフトボール
gogo7188のように、バックホーンのアシッドマン
ゴリラアタックのように、彼らはもっと
マイナー
でした。
私はまだ彼らが持っていると思いますか、それはそうでは
ありません
私はその期間からのええと本当に良いええと
パンクロックを知りませんが、私は
本当にええと
ケチャップを演奏したことがないので
、言うのは難しいです
が確かにgogo7188のようなバンド
彼らは
絶対に信じられないほど素晴らしいので、
あなたがパンクロックに興味があるなら、確かに
それらをチェックしてください私は
時々外国のアクセントのような英語を話す
人がアメリカのアクセントで不完全な話し言葉の日本人を好むかもしれないと思いますか
アクセントが好きなネイティブの英語話者について話しているときは
、ほとんどの場合
、イギリス英語のように話しているアメリカ人のような英語のようなものだと思います。それは
別の種類の英語です。
そうですね、それはええと
、いわばアクセントではありません。それは、英語を
話すネイティブの中国人の話者のように
まったく違うので
、外国語を話すことになると、ええと思います。
日本人外国訛り
があることには良いこと
はないと思います
ほとんどの
場合、外国訛りがあっても害はない
と思いますが、同時に
近いと思います 私の意見では、あなたの日本人
は
、基本的にすべてのネイティブの
日常の日本のすべての相互作用にのみ役立つアクセントの響きの点でネイティブである
ため
、私の友人は高校でwrxターボを持っていました
素晴らしい車は寄付マイケルに感謝します
鹿児島に住んでいるあなたのコメントです。鹿児島に住んでいるのが好きなら
、これはあなたの状況に完全に依存するので、私はまだ標準的な高低アクセントを勉強する必要があります。
近い将来、鹿児島に住んでいるのを見ることができます。
おそらく、日本に住んで
いる間は、残りの
人生でも、鹿児島方言に
すべて入ることができます。
地元の人に近いですが、
日本国内に引っ越すかもしれないと感じたら、私はおそらく
標準的な日本語にもっと集中する
でしょう。
同じ会話を何度も繰り返すのは嫌だと言うと
、ある時点でイライラする可能性がある
ので
、日本のある地域で方言を拾い
、その後、日本の別の地域
に移動すると、 日本の新しい地域で新しい人
との会話をすべて費やして
、その前に
その方言をどのように拾ったかを説明する必要があります。その
ような小さなやり取り
があなたを苛立たせる可能性がある場合
は、おそらく標準に固執すると思います
日本語です
が、それが日本ジュール
の会話の上にあるので、
必然的に
そうなると思うなら、そうそう、それはあなたの状況に本当に依存し
ます 薩隅に滞在し
たい薩隅方言
は非常に独特です
が、ちなみに標準の日本語に固執するかもしれないと思うなら
、ここに本があります
[音楽]
この本
にほんごアクセント日本語のアクセント日本語の方言のアクセントの紹介
基本的に
この本は日本語ですが
、
薩隅方言のセクション
があります。本当に早く確認できるように
、この本にセクションがある
ので、必要に応じて調べる必要があるかもしれ
ません。 薩隅方言に固執
するので
、私の若いコメントに感謝します。
新しい法律が可決された今、入れ墨はどのように受け入れられますか。
将来的には緩和される
と思いますか。
過去のようなyoutubeのような
ものの出現は、テレビのような入れ墨のある人や
、おそらく特別なliのようなものの外でそのようなものを見るのは非常にまれであることを知っています
元ヤクザのメンバーかその
ようなものです
が、twitch、twitter、
tiktok、youtubeなど、自分のチャンネルを通じて日本で人気を博す
こと
ができるようになっ
たので、そうしない人
が増えるでしょう。
彼ら
が入れ墨をしているという事実と、そのために日本
が
時間の経過とともにゆっくりと国際的になっているという事実を検閲する必要があり
ます私は時間の経過とともに入れ墨
を取り巻く汚名がゆっくりとゆっくりとしかし確実に
消えると
思います」
近い将来、間違いなく見つめられるので、
今後も注意してください。
少しの間、パトレオン限定の
ライブストリームを作成します。
4時から4時
前まで
行って、その時点でストリームを終了する
かもしれません。おそらく、Twitterで[音楽]のツイートをリツイートするかもしれません。
私は李です
誰か他の人が入りたいの
なら、私たちは続けます4時まで行くので
さらに45分かそこら
申し訳ありません
コメント私が答えた最後のコメントは何でしたか見てみましょう
私は
1つのum
がそこに絵文字を持っていると答えました ええ、
どうやってその正確な絵文字をどのように表現し
ますか？ローマ字の文字だけを考えて使用している
場合は、寄付にも感謝しますが、
現在のPCが構築されていることに感謝している
ので、
基本的に完全にimacの新しい2020を特定しました
imac8テラバイト10ギガビットイーサネット64
ギガバイトのRAM
私は自分でRAMをインストールしました
。これはラジオだと思います。
グラフィックカードとは何ですか
。10コアのintel3.6
ギガヘルツプロセッサ
と16ギガバイトのamdradeonpro5700xtが搭載されています。
ビデオメモリを搭載しているので、これが私のPCビルドであり、
デュアルモニターを使用しているので、
ここ
でエルガトストリーム
が点灯する
ようになっています。 かなり違うみたい
私は自分のコンピューターからそれをオンにすることができますが、
それから私はここの側面に2番目のuh 4k
モニターを持っているので、私
は一種のデュアルスクリーン
5k 4kuhimacを持っています
アップルが好きな人もいれば、アップルが嫌いな人
もいるので、私は本当にアップルが好きなので、
これは
私が今まで持っていた最初
の
適切なデスクトップです。 私
は長い間MacBookPro
を使って
いましたが、実際に元気になったのは2020年でした。そのため
、MacBook Proに問題があり、
最近Twitterで販売した人もい
ますが、
今では 私はこの適切なデスクトップを手に入れましたそれは
ちょうど私の神のようですなぜ私はなぜ私は
以前にこれらの1つを手に入れなかったのですか
このようなライブストリームなので、その
一部をビジネス費用として償却できる
ので、
お金を失っていました。
特に
、私が行うすべての作業は私のオフィスで行われるため、すべての作業をラップトップから
行うことができます。移植性は必要ありません。また、
ipadもあるので、本当に必要な場合はそれを使用できます。
でも、そんなに多くする必要はないので
、あなたの愛を愛してみよう。
数年後に日本に行きたいのは、必見の
場所があります。
少し早いですが
、
横浜のum minato midahiは、おそらく日本で一番好きな場所です。
東京はどのように見えるかと思っていたのです
が、東京は実際には好奇心旺盛で
、ほとんどの地域でそれほど近代的ではありません。
東京は
人々の東京のイメージと比較する
と、湊みらいは、建築が実際に始まる前に
、単一の建築家または単一の建築家チームが
設計を
決定した
ように、本当に明白
なええと、あなたは何をしているのかを知ることができます
私は忘れると言う 英語で言うと、
それは都市にとって意図的な構造であり、
本当に美しくモダンで
、歩き回って海
と
美しい建築物を見ることができます
。私が行く場所であるミナトミラが大好きです。私の好きな
キャラクター
はオバゾンです。
後でそのキャラクターを使って私たちに別れを告げる
私はおそらく後でそれをするのを忘れるでしょう
それで多分
私は今それをすることができます
その
ビデオは今とてもうまくいけば
、それが私がそのビデオで言った最後の行だったと思います
ファイナルファンタジーviiのリメイクが出たときに彼らが
私をフォローしたり申し訳なかったりした
場合、
これは私が言いたい
ことです。元のファイナルファンタジー7は
私のお気に入りのゲームなので、
2つのゲームのうちの1つです。 それ
私はゲームをプレイした場所でプレイしたことがあり、
10年後
、ゲームをプレイするのに何十時間も費やし
たことを後悔していなかったように
感じました。
それが人としてのクリエーターとして私に追加されたように
、私はピアノやそのようなもので多くの曲のように演奏する方法を学び
ました
が、
それがジェットグラインドラジオだと思っている人のための他のゲームで
も非常に種類があります
ドリームキャストでスタイルの多い独特のゲームですが、
基本的に
は大学を卒業した後はビデオゲームを
プレイしたことはありませんでした。 これ
は、プレイしないと後悔するだろうと思います。
すぐに
そのゲームをプレイするためにプレイステーション4を購入し
、少しだけツイッチでストリーミングしました
が、停止しなければなりませんでした。
少しbiを得た 忙しすぎ
てゲームを終了しました。
最近プレイしたのですが、エアロバイク
で夜にエクササイズをして
いると、コントローラーを持っ
て画面を同時に見ることができるようになりました。
私のセットアップです
が、そのゲームのリメイク
は、タイトル画面が画面にキャラクターを表示したときのように、オープニングの最初の2分間のように、完全な故障の
ように泣き叫ぶようなもの
でした。 その期間の私の人生の中で
、私が
それをプレイすることを決定する前に、私は
あなたが知っているように本当に過ごしたいと思っていました
150中古のps4を購入し、
それからおそらく
これにさらに67ドル このゲームですが、
プレイを開始するとすぐに、
この体験を再び得るために千ドルを費やしたようでした。なぜなら
、キャラクター
、音楽を演出するストーリー、バトル
システム
、それに関するすべてがうまくいったからです。 ここ
にゲームの少しのパディングがあります
それがなかっ
たらいいのに彼らがそれを追加した理由がわかりますがええと
私は確かにそのゲームをプレイしたことを後悔していません
だから、
ええと
、私の女の子が就学前になり始めたら、将来、
ツイッチのようなゲームでもう少しライブストリーミングを行う予定です。なぜなら、今は
ビデオゲームをプレイするのに十分な時間がなく、同時に運動しないから
です。 週に1時間以上のようです
が、女の子が学校に通い始めたら、
ゲームにもっと興味を持ち
たいと思っています。それ
は、私はクリエイターとして馬鹿げているように聞こえ
ますが、ゲームはストーリーテリングの非常に良い形になる
と思うからです。
ライターとしてストーリーテリングや
会話のように、何よりも
注意を払わなければなら
ないので、プレイしたことのないゲームは私たちの最後です
が、それは本当に本当に良いものだと聞いてい
ます 本当に良い
マーティン・スコッセの映画の
ように、私はそれをプレイした場合、私たちの最後のようなゲームからライターとして多くを学ぶことができると思いますので
、この時代のビデオゲームについては多くのことが言われていますi
決して時間を無駄にしているだけではないと思います。
私は一人称シューティングゲームのようなものにはあまり興味がありません。
以前は格闘ゲームに
夢中になっていたのですが、鉄拳のように
ある程度死んでいるか生きていますが、
今はそう思います。
今後、正当化できる唯一の種類のゲーム
は、
本当に強力なストーリーのように本当に良いゲームを持っているゲームになるでしょう。
なぜなら、それは私がクリエイターとしてのユーチューバーとしてええとからたくさん拾うことができるものになるからです。
少し戻って、
すべての質問に答えていることを確認しましょう。
寄付してくれたすべての人に感謝します。
ビッグテックのトピックについて
本当に
感謝しています。
ファイするのは難しい その
趣味の友人
ええと、私は、
PCの構築のように、そして米国の技術の
熱意のように、
linustechのヒントのようなYouTubeチャンネルのおかげではるかに主流になっ
ていると思います。
ええと、テックとPCの
ようなもの
は、アメリカではもっと主流になっていますが
、日本ではまだかなりニッチなニッチであると思うので、日本で友達を見つけるのは少し難しいかもしれません。
不可能だと言っているわけではありませんが、
そうですね、私は
それを改善するために日本と日常生活を使ってきた州よりもおそらく少し難しいと思います
が、
少し孤独な人でもある人
は、日本に物理的にいない場合は、話をする方法を見つけるの
が難しい
ので、始めるためのアドバイスはありません。あなたができる最善のこと
は、私が
何をするかです。 つまり、YouTube
チャンネル
を作成して公開するということです。
これは、適切に実行するようにプレッシャーをかけ、毎日5分のvlogを作成するだけで、
おそらく10分
は、その日に行ったことについての長さのようになります。
そういうことを言う
と、自分で作っただけで、
誰もこのビデオを見ることがないように、たるむのはとても簡単
です。私は本当に一生懸命努力する必要はありません
が
、他の人のふりをしてビデオをもう一度作成する場合
あなたが知らない人
はそれを見るでしょうそれはあなたにそれを適切に行うように圧力をかけるでしょう
それでそれはおそらく
あなたにとって良いアドバイスになると思いますそして
明らかに
私はこれについて以前に話しましたがより
ネイティブなインプット
リピートで映画を見るの
も上手くいくので、毎日何時間も
かけて日本の映画を聴いてから
、少しだけ
出力し
てみてください。出力を少し遅らせるべきだと言う人もいます。
最初の数年間を日本語で勉強するのと同じように
、入力にもっと集中するかもしれません。それは
合理的だと思います。それも有益だと思い
ますが、勉強しているのであれば
、1年以上経っています。
ネイティブの意見がたくさんあった
ので、自分自身
を表現し、自分の考えを日本語で表現することを学び始めるのは良いことだと
思います。
ですから
、音楽の読み方と演奏方法を知っ
ている人
はいますか？
高低アクセントを聞き、学ぶのを手伝って
ください道元からあなたの名前道元を取得しました
かええと禅寺ありがとええええ私
は本当に
禅仏教に夢中になっていた私は高校の禅仏教の
段階の
ようでした 禅
仏教は、
オオカミ
ラルフエマーソンロルフラルフワルドエマーソンのようなアメリカの超越運動と多くの類似点を持っ
ています。
ええと
、今は頭のてっぺんから相手の名前を思い出せません
が、似ているところがたくさんあるので、高校でそれについて論文を
書いたのは面白いと思いました
が、
ええ、 高校の禅仏教に
本当に興味がありますええと、それは本当に
面白い
と思いますええと、
あなた
が音楽を演奏でき、日本語と日本語の高低アクセント
を学ぶことになるとあなただけが役立つ良い年を過ごすことができる程度だと思います
私の耳
昔はピアノをたくさん弾いていたのですが、あまり良くありませんが、
ピアノを習う
ことで私が傷つくとは思いませんし、私のパトレオン
を使う人もたくさんい
ます。 ええと、以下にリンクされ
ているのは、絶対
音感を持っているか、高低アクセントをしているの
か、給料チェックをしていないの
か、アカデミックレベルのように音楽をやっているのか
、音楽を使っているのか、
キャリアと10回のうち9回
その種のインディ 個々のええと
、さまざまな
周波数や音楽などの
そのような理解は役立つだけな
ので、確かにそれ
はほとんどの状況でほとんどの人に役立ちます
古典的なブームのためのヒントリソース
ええと、古典的なブンガコは本当にただの問題だと思います
古典的な
ブンガコは現代のブンガのようなものとは非常に異なるので、それは実際に
あなたがそれをするのに何時間費やすのかというような力の力です。
その特定の
ことからあなたが知っていることあなたは期間を知っています
ええと私はそれ
が正しいかもしれないええと11月と呼ばれていると思いますが
ええとワガヒの
人々はもうそれを使用していません
そうです
、もう表示されない用語に慣れ
ておく必要があります。それを実行できる唯一の方法は、ブルートフォースを使用することです。
プッシュプッシュプッシュ
ペルソナについてたくさん聞いた
ことがあるので、もう少し時間があればチェックしてみたいシリーズかもしれないと思います。
ファイナルファンタジー6をプレイしてみたいです。
ペルソナシリーズをプレイしてみてください。また
、私たちの最後の人
は、ツシマの幽霊が好きかもしれませ
ん。そのゲーム
では、設定のようなものであり
、話が良いと聞いているのかわかりません。
しかし、それ
はゲームのメインドローのようではありません私
は戦闘や設定、そして
グラフィックスや一般的なもののように
、そのゲームは本当に本当に良いはずだと思い
ますが、それは
私が大丈夫だと理解していることからの話ではありません
youtubeがあなたのために拾い始めたのはいつ
ですか
、そして何が原因で何が原因でし
たか申し訳ありませんが
何が原因でしたか
ほとんどのYouTubeユーザーですが
、誰かが突然
シーンに爆発することは非常にまれです。
私にとっては
、3年以上YouTubeをやっていて、ほぼ
3年間、毎週アップロードするだけでした。 この時点で、私は毎週
アップロードを停止しなければなりませんでした。
なぜなら、私は
一日のほとんどを
見て
過ごす双子の娘がいる
から
です。
努力不足で見ることができ、視聴が止まる
ので、
YouTubeをやり
たいのなら、どんなジャンルのジャンルでも100を入れないといけないと思います。
ええと、私は数回、日本語を学ぶ
ようなredditのように
、彼ら
が私のビデオの1つを早い段階で拾ったようにそれを書くの
が好きでし
た。 もう少し
ユーチューブをやってから1年以上経ち
ました
が、私がブーストのようになったようなインスタンスのそれぞれは、私が
私のような千人以上のブーストを取得することはめったにありませんでした
ジョーイとアルボとのコラボレーションをしたとき、比較的大きな後押しを得
ました。過去にクリス・クリス・ブロードと一緒に何かをしたときのように、過去に
彼と一緒にqとaのようにしたように
、それはあなたです
他の人
のチャンネルに何百万人ものチャンネル登録者がいても
、時間と労力
を費やしてそれに
固執していても、他の人のチャンネルに表示されるように突然成功することはできません。
たぶん
、あなたは私の意見で成功するでしょう
が、ええ
、ジョーイとアルボ、クリスとpdrを含め、これまで私を助けてくれたすべて
の人
に感謝します。  youtubeは絶対に
あなたのビジネスを成長させるのに役立ちました
私のビデオを見る人は時々youtubeからパトレオンにやって来るので、
宇部は私の主な収入源です、そして
私はyoutube自体からもお金を稼ぐので、
youtube
は私が絶対に大丈夫なことのために不可欠です
チャット
オーケーええと、
こんにちは犬と先生
あなたが非ネイティブの先生であるときにあなたが日本語を上達させるために最も重要な3つのことは何ですかあなたが非ネイティブの
先生であるときそれは
難しい質問
です あなたが教師である
なら、日本語を学ぶのをやめられないように、常に日本語を聞く必要があり
ます。
言語も
、高低アクセントをまったく勉強したことがない場合は
、高低アクセントについて学ぶことは、言語の聞き方、ひいては高低アクセントの方法を根本的に変える
ため、多くの人にとって非常に目を見張る
ものになります。
あなたが言語を再現するとき、
特に
あなたが英語を母国語とする人の
ように、多くのことを
助けることができるので、それは2つのことだと思います
。3番目のことは
おそらくうまくいくと思います。
日本語を母国語としない教師の場合に
やらなければならないことのトップ3のリスト私ができることの1つは
、生徒と一緒に人々に正直に
なり、私の日本語はそうではないと言うことだと
思います。 私は
ネイティブスピーカーではない
ので
、ルールと知識を覚えておくために話しているルールを聞いて
ください。ただし、
日本語の映画を見たり、アニメを見たりして、ネイティブから入力をもらいましょ
う。 ネイティブ入力を取得する必要があるかもしれません
ので、
私が実際にルールに入る前のように、ピッチアクセントで
パトレオンの私のシリーズを受講する人々のように、これらすべてのルールを
ネイティブ入力を取得する必要があるようなビデオがいくつかあります。
情報
頭の中でルールの種類を知っていて
、ルールのイメージのようになっているが、
実際にどのような音が聞こえるかわからない場合は、ネイティブの入力もたくさん得られない限り、それはすべて無意味だと教えています ネイティブスピーチのように、
最近
、すべてのレッスンの
録音をネイティブ録音に置き換え始めました
。これも、ネイティブ入力が
重要だと思うので、生徒が
尊敬する可能性のある本当に良い
ことになると思います。
正直言って、私の日本語は完璧ではないと言って
くれますが、xyとzを使えば、日本語をさらに上達させる
ことができます。そうすれ
ば、日本語が完璧でない限り、それができるかもしれません。
ええと、クリスありがとうございます
。あなたがここにいるかどうかはわかりませんが、
クリスがリツイートしたのかもしれません。
チャットでクリスについて言及している人もい
ます。ありがとうございました。
またすぐにコラボレーションできることを願っています。
私はawkになることができます 私たちが一緒に行っ
た最後のオイタビデオのような私たちのライブライブストリームの病棟私
はそれらのキャラクターの両方が素晴らしいとは言え
ません
私はエアロ
バイクでエクササイズをし
ます。アニメを見るか、
ファイナルファンタジー7を日本語
で再生します。声の演技は
、サブまたは
タイトルも日本語に切り替える必要がありますが、
ナルトをもう一度見ると、そうではありません。
特に、
疾風伝は本当に良い
シリーズだと思います。クリエイティブな執筆に入る前に見始めたので、
今
までに一度も取り上げなかった特定のエピソードをもう一度見ているようなものがたくさんあります。
そして、私
が演出のように注意を払い始める前
に、私の意見のように細かいディテールのようなものは、
それがあまり大げさではないように聞こえるが、多くの時間があれば、ええと良い良い芸術のよう
になります ええと、ナルトとii
のエピソードの多くに入った努力と考え
は、
おそらく
感情的な影響のためにフラッシュバックが多すぎるとしても、それは素晴らしいシリーズだと思いますが、
ええ、私はそれがそうではないと思います
モンスターのようなシリーズのように良い
モンスターは
信じられないほど素晴らしいと思いますが、
ええと、それは
今でも良いシリーズだと思います。
ホローライブとは何かを知っているの
は、AVチューバーになるためのツールのようなものだとは
思いませんが、私は
時代遅れだとは思い
ません。 勉強のために一人で日本に引っ越しているかもしれませんが、
おそらく
私が以前に言ったのと同じアドバイスをあなたに
与えるでしょう。
以前にあなたはthを行うことができます
日本に着く前にそれができれば
、実際のネイティブスピーカーと一緒に日本での時間を十分に活用できる可能性が高くなります
ので
、できるだけ早く快適ゾーンから出
てください。 大きな違いを生むが、
最新の作品をスコープしていると言って
も、モンスター以外に彼からの作品は見たことがない
が
、モンスターはとても良いので、おそらくチェックする必要がありますが、
残念ながら私は試してみません 好きな漫画を調べてみて
くださいええと、漫画はあまり読まないのです
が、普段はアニメを見るだけですが、私の
好きなアニメは、
最近、明らかに過去2、3回のように京神に夢中になっているモンスターです。
ええと、私はモンスターが好きな
ので、15分くらいで
行かなくてはいけません。それから、パトレオン限定のライブストリームをやらなければなりませんが、
このストリームがどのように進んだかには本当に満足しています。
多分それがベカウかわからないので、これまでは面白いです se私は
けいれんではなくyoutubeでこれをやっています
が、私が最終的なファンタジーviiをストリーミングしていたとき、
人々
が私を聞いたりビデオゲームをプレイしたりするのではなく、私が話すのを聞きたいだけなのか
わかりませ
んが、
933 同時視聴者をTwitchで
これまでよりもはるかに高く変換する
ので、これ
をもう少し頻繁に試してみると、頻繁に行うほど多くなると思い
ます。
特別な機会のように、
視聴者が毎回ダウンすることはおそらくないでしょうが
、このようなライブストリーミングは時々行うのが楽しいことを知っていると思います。
youtubeライブストリームなので、
twitchとyoutubeはかなり
異なるプラットフォームですええ私は
twitchよりもyoutubeに多くのチャンネル登録者がいます
それは大きなこと
です
ユーチューブでの1つの発表私は私が行くつもりだったと言った
ストリーミングを開始します
が、YouTubeのほとんどの人
が私のコメディー動画を見てくれているので、日本語でビデオゲームをプレイする
よりも、日本語について話したり、日本語で冗談を言ったりすることはあまりありません。
その
事後に宣伝
しないでください。私は2、3のコメントがわからないのが好きなだけの人が少しいるので
、彼らはああ、それは残念だと
言っていました。  twitchは
twitch.tvであり、私のyoutubeと同じように私のツイッターと同じですが、
私の女の子が学校に通い始めたら、将来またもっとツイッチ
を行う予定です。 けいれんし
ますが、iiiの空き時間がほとんどないため、ほとんど使用
しません。
ライブストリームのようにビデオゲームをプレイする
のに2時間かかる場合は、その時間をパトレオンのレッスンの作成に割り当てる方がよいでしょう。
またはの
ように
スクリプトを書くように コメディー
ビデオなどです
が、これは特別な機会です。
これも、
YouTubeでライブストリームを
1年以上行っていないためです。また、この新しいセットアップを取得してから
、新しいものになっています。
ちなみにこれをチェックしてください
私は
最近これを手に入れましたええとスタンディング
デスクそしてええとこれは素晴らしいです
私は
2年前のようにこれを手に入れたいと思います
繰り返しになりますが、10分ほどで行か
なくてはいけないので、見える質問に答えてみますが、明らかに大丈夫でなくてもいいのなら、これがスーパーチャットで目立つ最後のチャンスかも
しれません。 日本では人の扱いが違う
2018年に行ったのですが、私が話す前に
私は日本人ではなかったと
言うことができました
。 それ アメリカのファッションにおける日本の
ファッションは非常に異なって
おり、メイクアップスタイルの
ようであり、ヘアカットのような一般的な外観と
そのような
ものは通常非常に異なるので
、あなたが民族的に
日本人
であり、日本人のように服を着ているなら、私は思います
また、
日本人がきちんと話せなかったら、きっと驚くでしょう
し、私のような西洋人よりも、日本の文化的ルールの側面についてもっと知ってほしいと期待しているかもしれません。
日本に住む日本人のように
、他の
国が存在することや、他の国で日本人
が生まれ育つことはできないことを知らないというわけではない
ので、私が
実際
にアメリカで生まれたようだったと言えば または、
おそらく私の経験で
は、そのような友人が何人
かいたので、彼らはあなたが日本人であることを理解するだろうと彼らは理解するでしょう
。 完璧ではなく
、ここで生まれ育った典型的な人ほど日本文化について知らないので、日本
の人や外国人の半数が
毎年ますます一般的になっているので、少しはわかるかもしれませ
ん 少し違う扱いですが、ほとんどの人にとって
は大きなハードルのようなものになるとは思いませんが、
逸話的なアドバイスはそうか、逸話的な
意見
ではなく、ええと、
サイクロンが大好きです。
素晴らしいと思いますが、そのランタンも素晴らしいと思いますが、
誰かがこれに気づいてよかったです。これは実際にはこれが実際
の寺院のランタンです。
ええ
、実際の日本の禅僧を道元にした寺院
です。 彼の寺院のランタンなので
、義父の母なので、義理の祖母
がそこに行って、
彼女が若いときにこのランプを手に
入れました。
201年に戻った高校の日本人 7
学習を続けるためにどのようなリソースをお勧めしますか
私の学習を続けるために
あなたがアニメから拾うことができる悪い習慣はありますか
私は
それからかなり学びました
ええとアニメからの悪い習慣は
あまりにも多くの屈曲で
話し、
文化のようなものがたくさんあるという事実は、
影響の範囲ではなく
、友達のサークルのように
、家族の
サークルとは異なり、仕事の
サークルとは異なり、異なる言語を使用するようになります。
それぞれのマナー主義の
ように、アニメから日本語を学ぶだけで、
新劇の京人のようなファンタジーアニメの
ように、それらを知る可能性は
はるかに低く、文化的な偽物を作る可能性が高くなります。
テラスハウスのようなnetflix
や先ほど話したyoutubeyoutubeのように、たくさんのネイティブ入力を組み合わせてやるの
もいいかもしれません。
日本語のネイティブスピーカーとの1週間のレッスンでは、
um italkiのようなもので失礼します。
なぜなら
、そのサービスの教師は、余分なお金を稼ぎたい日本人だけでなく、
実際の日本人の教師のような資格を持っていることがよくあるからです。
または何か
時々彼らはそうですが、しばしばあなた
はそれらのサービスで本当に良い先生を得ることができる
ので、
おそらく2つの組み合わせをするのは良いことです
が、
ネイティブ入力が常に繰り返し映画を見る一番
の
ことは誰かにあなたのコメディを見てもらいますか
フィードバックのための
コメディスキットええと、youtubeに投稿する前に、あなたが購入したアパート
のツアービデオを投稿したことは
あります
か？  yamatong mr yabatangと一緒に撮ったビデオは、私が
アップロードする前に彼がチェックできるように、事前にリンクを送っ
ていたかもしれません。
まるでおじさんのマグネットシリーズのような本当に強烈な台本のように
やっているのと同じように
、日本の外国人であることが州に戻って、
これらすべてのやりとりが好きである
ということについて、このような作品全体のようにやっている私の25分のビデオのようなものです
ネイティブスピーカーに事前に台本をチェックしてもらった、本当に強烈な日本人がたくさんいるこの本当に長いインテンシブな作品は、
このように、時にはこのことを言った方が自然だと彼らが言ったことがかなり
ありました
とにかくこれを
やろうと言って、
もっと自然に聞こえるかもしれませんが
、代わりにそうするかもしれ
ませんが、10回に9回
はスクリプトを書いています。
ネイティブスピーカーに見てもらわない
で、それをチェックして
からアップロードします。
コメディについてのフィードバックも得られ
ないので、ほとんどの場合、私の部屋にいる私だけが私の
ことをやっています。
あなたがboするアパートのツアービデオ
買ったマンションはやったけど
、ちょっと怖かったので降ろしたんだけど
、コメントで誰か
が場所のレイアウトで識別できると言ってくれ
たので降ろしたけど 非常に近い将来、
実際に私が作成する可能性のある次のビデオ
はオフィスツアーになる可能性があるので
、次のビデオ
が本当に依存していると思うかもしれないし
、しないかもしれないと期待するかもしれません。
わかりました。
もう1つか2つの
質問をしなければなりません。あなたやチャットの他の誰かが
、英語の
会話の有無にかかわらず基本的な会話をしている日本人の話者がいるリソースを知って
いますか。英語の字幕を意味していると
思います。 ジャパニーズポッド101
のユーチューブチャンネルのビデオ
タイトルは2時間の日本人の会話のようなものだと思います
そして私
はジャパを学ぶumの人々のためのものであるようなビデオを想像します
neseにはおそらく
オンまたはオフにできる字幕が
あるので、
大丈夫かどうかを確認してください。
もう1分ほどで始めましょ
う。ええと、ええと、スキミングを見てみましょう。
パトレオンのライブストリームもセットアップしなければならないので、おそらくドーミングが好き
ですが、このストリームに来てくれたすべての人に感謝します
iiもう一度、将来
はもう少しライブストリームを行うことができると思い
ます
おそらく毎月ほど頻繁ではありませんが、
おそらく年に1回以上、
娘たちも学校に通い始めたら、ひきつりの
ようになります。多分、隔月で隔月のように
ライブを行うことができます。 ストリームかそのようなものですが
、今日は素晴らしい時間を過ごしまし
た。出てきたすべての
人に感謝します。これがどのように進んだか本当に満足しています。
みなさん、この
ライフスタイルを可能にしてくれます。この
種の仕事が大好きです。私の仕事が大好きです。
日本語を教えたり、日本語でスキットを作ったりするのが大好き
です
。 皆さん、またすぐに
感謝
します。もしあなたが常連客なら、私はちょうど
5分ほどでパトレオンにライブで唾を吐くと思います。